the legend is that you realized you
wanted to be a professional wrestler
quite young uh so did you actually
become a high school wrestler in part
because you even had this ambition in
your head
not even in part 100 like the plan was
uh this is i tell this story in stand up
all the time
i was five years old uh cleveland didn't
even have an arena
so we had to drive out to rich the
richfield coliseum that's where the cavs
played when i was a kid
and we sat in the farthest away seats
and there was no big titan trons no big
shows it was just
entrances and guys came out and uh after
the show
we were so far away i told my dad i go i
want to be a wrestler i want to do this
and he goes okay but
you know you got to start wrestling in a
little bit different style so
at five years old he signed me up for
just one
one or two days a week wrestling with my
friends uh at my grade school
and i no joke i walked in the door and
go where's the ring where's the chairs
where's everything
no no this is different and i go okay
so i i did it and the whole goal through
grade school high school college even
was like i go if i can break some
records in college and you can google my
name as like this all-time winning
wrestler
they'll have to give me a try out right
because you know and uh
and luckily that's that's what it was uh
just because having a background where
you can google my name
it was like i just as i graduated i
broke the record for most wins at my
school which is
one of the goals i had that's actually a
question because
when i was a kid you know i had fanciful
thoughts like oh i'm going to
be a pro wrestler and like i had some
moniker but you know
nowhere near as uh
as action-oriented as as your ambition
so did your family have an athletic
background like uh how
realistic was this when you were
hatching this plan back in
yeah you know people will go like oh i
told my parents i was going to hollywood
to become a star and they're like yeah
right or something but
i was a little bit of a showman or you
know
annoying i guess always on as a child
even so
when i was like hey this is what i want
to do no one was like yeah right they're
like oh yeah that makes sense
and i was like okay we made a deal i
made a deal with my parents i said
this doesn't work out for a lot of
people uh i will graduate college first
to have something to fall back on
back when that was a big deal graduating
college you know when it made sense
yeah no i remember
[Music]
and i sorry i did that and uh i go once
i graduate then i'm gonna
i'm gonna go to law school during the
day and wrestling school at night and
it's a whole i had it all planned out
and um and uh luckily um
i moved to arizona to live in my uh um
and uncle's
guest bedroom to have residency for a
year
and then it would turn out that law
school would be way cheaper than it
would normally be
had it all worked out yeah had it all
worked out i never would have been able
to do all the hours and do wrestling
school and all that stuff but while i
was waiting
to go to school at asu i got my try out
with wwe
so it all worked out somehow
yeah the the the fact that you had law
school
uh you know as your back burner or your
your fallback i gotta say man you dodged
a bullet
because like you as like
[Laughter]
you now is like the former champ
like you know 10-time intercontinental
champ or whatever whatever you are
like headliner versus like another
[ __ ] miserable lawyer i mean that's
like a very very
large gap so i would have been so
miserable
to have like we used to travel so much
before covid but i
used to have little bags in my eyes i
can't imagine being a miserable lawyer
keeps his shirt on all day long can't
like vent out the frustration
and constantly going or waiting to
hoping to be
part of work somewhere like junior
parker 20 years later oh
god i yeah i think i dodged a bullet i
think yeah you definitely did and the
world's better off for it
[Laughter]
we didn't need nick
that's for sure and i admire the fact
that you've gotten it to a point where
you are
branching out and doing all these things
that are clearly just born of you
that are like 100 nick um because i'm
sure
because because i'm sure wwe was not
like hey nick
you should do you shouldn't study comedy
for years and years and then go out
there and like open mic it up
like like i doubt that was high on their
list
uh so so tell me about how that
developed because i love it
i love the fact that um that you've
taken up another crab despite being at
the top of your field
uh and ta and and gone to another field
that is brutally difficult very
unforgiving like there's no faking it
uh you know your your fame
and the built up affection that some of
the people in the audience have for you
last for approximately two seconds
and then it's like hey if you can't make
me laugh then [ __ ] you
so like uh so so how the heck did you
did you start pushing in that direction
uh okay there's a couple pieces there
one it's very similar to wrestling which
is wild
like it's you on the road you travel you
but with wrestling there's someone else
in the ring that you can blame
or play off of or something but no
matter what when you go up on the stage
i am still nervous i'm at like i don't
know
50 or 60 shows i've done something like
that and i go up there and i
have a whiskey beforehand and i go up
there and i'm like nervous
and you go and all of a sudden you just
see all these eyes on you and if
it's a wrestling ring i'm 15 years in i
go i know what i can do we can get them
back with something here but if i go up
there and
stutter or miss a line and go talk over
a word
and they're just staring there like this
like you're really good at wrestling
why why does this suck and you're like
oh god
but um i also so i i kind of found like
a loophole to where
i get to try out my material but also
wrestling fans get to come and get their
autographs or a picture with me or
something but then they have
i do it beforehand and then they have to
sit through the show
to deal with me with the material so but
i'm also smart enough i go i know
there's gonna be a bunch of hardcore
wrestling fans on my show so i usually
try and do a formula of like
20 you read the internet you know the
rumors little
little brock lesnar dig about him not
showing up or some kind of joke for the
hardcore fans
and then there's like 20 percent more of
like they know who
the rock john cena and hulk hogan is and
i'm like the to show something i just
tell them i was john cena or whatever
and that's all you need to know
and then i go there's like comedy fans
and people who just came to a show
and it's i about 60 i do just
me going to chipotle me wrestling in con
college
me on tinder or bumble or something and
at least whatever happens to me so i
find a happy medium
and then uh i'm very lucky that we can
do um because uh for at first i couldn't
do
i'm headlining i can't do an hour no way
now and
uh we found a way for sarah tiana who is
a pro comic and really funny
to where she went up ahead of me she
kills for 20 minutes
i would do 20 or 25 minutes and then we
would do a q a back and forth where we
roast each other we actually went on
comedy central and do like a rose battle
where we would roast each other but also
yeah i i saw that it was pretty funny
that was like like uh god it was great
you got
no it was great and you guys have great
chemistry you guys clearly are close
friends um
i it's it's awesome you found a partner
in comedy crime
it's wild just putting putting jokes
online and
fans who are in some kind of
entertainment with that i just met
sarah walking into the comedy store in
l.a just watching shows
and we talked and you and then we became
friends and then we became
friends to where we can kind of roast
each other non-stop and then now
we have like this brother-sister thing
where we just roast each other the
entire time and
it's fans like it's the the best part of
the comedy show because we're just
riffing and having fun and
i'm not looking at my notes and sweating
and trying to think of a punch line i'm
just we're just going to go with it and
it's
it's worked out really well it's awesome
we've had so much fun with it
again so impressive like it you know
that the thing i love about it is that
you clearly have such like a perpetual
growth mindset because like very very
few people who are at the top of
uh the wrestling field getting like paid
a lot of money would
be like you know i'm going to do this
other thing that is going to be really
difficult
it's going to be really difficult too
yeah
yeah and not exactly like throwing money
at me in the same way
and the rest of it and the fact that you
would line it up with your
wrestling events like it just shows the
love you know
it's really impressive to me uh yeah
i i love that and i and i want to be
good at it and i don't i don't want to
do the
we know you from wrestling hi and
they're already smiling when you walk
out i don't just tell some wrestling
story or something
because one day i mean people do that
and one day that could be a thing but i
go i'm actually trying to be a comic
so i'm working on material so i'll stick
in some stories so you guys stay in the
seats and come to the show
but i am actually trying a setup in a
punch line
and i've seen it no response and then
the sweat just starts pouring down your
face
anyway i was beating up john cena the
other day and then they wake back up
[Laughter]
but it seems like you have aspirations
in a number of different directions
and you seem like a the kind of person
who's very very goal oriented like what
is a goal that you're pushing
for either in wrestling or in comedy or
uh outside of those two uh it's it's a
little bit everything i i pride myself i
even when i just used to play sports and
want to be on saturday live as a kid
it's
it i am really goal oriented and every
day even to
like i'm going to have pizza on thursday
so let's get a second workout in on
wednesday and if you don't get it done
you're not going to get the pizza like
i even do that every week so i i do have
the goals and i
this year until covent hit we were i was
gonna double
the most amount of shows i had ever done
in a year we just announced a bunch of
different things
and i was in double those shows and i'm
not a fantastic comedian but
i'm okay and i'm learning and getting
the reps in
and i really wanted to double those
shows this year and
and uh i'm kind of half and half between
phoenix and la
and i was going to start getting a
couple different working on some tv and
movie stuff
and uh right now most things are shut
down but the goals are
to use that i can be used for
a funny political analyst in the back
pocket technically a comedian
technically a tv show guy i i did a
movie at wwe studios movie countdown
which was really bad but i was pretty
decent in it and and to have all these
and the wrestling and all these things
in my back pocket to where
just like when i was getting called up
that last time and didn't want to get
fired
to where i go here's every option i am a
modern day
renaissance man where would you like me
to
help you with this tv show this youtube
show
this comedy tour and to have everything
in my back pockets where
much like you know hoping wwe has no
option but to put me on tv
much like la has no option but to take
me for something or meet for a pitch
meeting because of all the stuff that
you know
so it's just it is those goals every day
in hindi
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation if you did
please do subscribe to yang speaks and
click on notifications so we can let you
know
every time we have a new episode
[Music]
you